science the thing we love and respect so
much we only allow scientists to be
portrayed by the likes of Arnold
Schwarzenegger Nicolas Cage and Al
Pacino that is how much we respect them
and the complexity of the work they do
science is constantly producing new
studies as you would know if you ever
watch TV a new study shows how sugar
might feel the growth of cancer a new
study shows late night snacking could
damage the part of your brain that
creates and stores memories a new study
finds pizza is the most addictive food
in America a new study suggests hugging
your dog is bad for your dog a new study
showing that drinking a glass of red
wine is just as good as spending an hour
at the gym what
that last one doesn't even sound like
science it's more like something you're
sassy aren't would wear on a t-shirt and
when studies aren't blanketing TV
they're all over your Facebook feed with
alerts like study finds liberals are
better than conservatives at smizing
your cat might be thinking about killing
you and scientific study shows that
bears engage in fellatio and by the way
I'm not interested let me know when
Bears start engaging in some mutually
pleasurable sixty-nining hashtag bear
pleasure
hashtag feminism fold up exactly Tom
calm once even ran the headline
scientists say smelling farts might
prevent cancer which I would say was the
most unfortunate thing time ever
published but then this is a magazine
that once did a cover story on those
Asian American whiz kids the point is
there are now so many studies being
thrown around they can seem to
contradict one another in just the last
few months we've seen studies about
coffee that claim it may reverse the
effects of liver damage help prevent
colon cancer decrease the risk of
endometrial cancer and increase the risk
of miscarriage coffee today is like God
in the Old Testament it will either save
you or kill you depending on how much
you believe in its magic powers and
after a certain point all that
ridiculous information can make you
wonder is science to which the
answer is clearly no but there is a lot
of currently masquerading as
science so tonight we thought we talk
about a few of the reasons why and first
not all scientific studies are equal
some may appear in less than legitimate
scientific journals and others may be
subtly biased because of scientists
feeling pressured to come up with i
catching positive results my success as
a as a scientist depends on me
publishing my findings and i need to
publish as frequently as possible in the
most prestigious outlets that I can now
that's true scientists under constant
pressure to publish with tenure and
funding on the line and to get published
it helps to have results that seem new
and striking cuz scientists know nobody
is publishing a study that says nothing
up with acai berries
and to get those results there are all
sorts of ways that consciously or not
you can tweak your study you could alter
how long it lasts or make your random
sample too small to be reliable or
engaging something that scientists call
pea hacking that's pea hacking with a -
not to be confused with facking at which
as I think everyone knows is a euphemism
for the Phillie Phanatic
yeah pea hacking is very complicated but
it basically means collecting lots of
variables and then playing with your
data until you find something that
counts as statistically significant but
is probably meaningless
for example the website 538 at surveyed
54 people and collected over a thousand
variables and through pea hacking the
results was able to find statistically
significant correlations between eating
cabbage and having an innie bellybutton
drinking iced tea and believing crash
didn't deserve to win Best Picture and
eating raw tomatoes and Judaism and the
only thing tomatoes have in common with
Judaism is that neither of them really
feel quite at home in the Upper Midwest
but but you don't even need to engage in
these kinds of manipulations to get
results that don't hold up even the best
design studies can get flukish results
and the best process that science has to
guard against that is the replication
study where other scientists redo your
study and see if they get similar
results unfortunately that happens way
less than it should
replication studies are so really funded
and is so underappreciated they never
get published no one wants to do them
there's no reward system there in place
that enables it to happen so you just
have all of these exploratory studies
out there that are taken as fact that
this is a scientific fact that's never
actually been confirmed exactly there is
no reward for being the second person to
discover something in science there's no
Nobel Prize for fact-checking and
incidentally there's no Nobel Prize for
fact-checking is a motivational poster
in Brian Williams's MSNBC dressing room
and
and for all those reasons for all
those reasons scientists themselves know
not to attach too much significance to
individual studies until they're placed
in the much larger context of all the
work taking place in that field but too
often a small study with nuanced
tentative findings gets blown out of all
proportion when it's presented to us the
lay public sometimes that happens when a
scientific body puts out a press release
summarizing the study for a wider
audience for instance earlier this year
a medical society hosted a conference at
which a paper was presented comparing
the effects of high and low flappin on
chocolate during pregnancy if that
sounds narrow and technical it was
supposed to be there wasn't even a
control group of women who didn't eat
chocolate and the study found no
difference in preeclampsia or high blood
pressure between women who ate the two
chocolates so there is no way a study
that boring can make it to television
right well wait because that Medical
Society issued a press release with the
much sexier but pretty misleading title
the benefits of chocolate during
pregnancy and because most TV producers
just read press releases this happens
turns out if you're pregnant eating 30
grams a day of chocolate that's about
two-thirds of a chocolate bar not the
whole chocolate bar could improve blood
flow to the placenta and benefit the
growth and development of your baby
especially in women at risk for
preeclampsia or high blood pressure in
pregnancy except that's not what the
study said it's like a game of telephone
the substance gets distorted at every
step and I can only imagine how someone
who watched that segment must have
described it the next day or the new
said our baby is made of chocolate and
it's okay if I eat it but only 2/3
and and it is not like the media needs
help blowing things out of proportion
remember that time story about farts and
cancer it turns out the study never
mentioned either of those things it just
pointed out that certain sulphide
compounds are useful pharmacological
tools to study mitochondrial dysfunction
and while that time story was later
heavily corrected the scientist told us
that we still get phone calls and emails
from strange radio and TV shows wanting
us to talk about farts which is clearly
a waste of their time they're doing
valuable work they shouldn't be wasting
her time fielding calls from Drivetime
djs gasps man and the beef and there is
no doubt some of this is on us the
viewing audience we like fun poppy
science that we can share like gossip
and TV news producers know it that is
why you constantly hear stuff like this
men listen up
a brand new study says a woman is more
open to romance when they are full
opposed to being hungry okay first of
all no anyone is more open to
anything when they aren't hungry but but
you should know that study involved only
20 women and you cannot presume that 20
women can speak for all women this is
science not the United States Senate and
then there was this I'm catching reports
from just last year a university in
England says drinking champagne every
week may help delay dementia and
Alzheimer's disease they say only one to
three glasses a week how'd a day a week
they can be effective for your health
fantastic news no it isn't no no because
there's a big issue with that study
aside from the fact that if you are
celebrating with champagne three times a
week your standard for celebration need
to be much higher
champagne is acceptable on New Year's
Valentine's birthdays and if and when
Henry Kissinger dies and that's it that
is it that is the full list but the
bigger issue is that study was performed
on rats and how do you not tell people
that and how do you not also show them
photos of the experiments oh you'd think
they would have paired it with some
cheese but it appears they went with
cocaine got that Sheikh those are sheep
rats it's not the drugs that make them
cool it's their confidence but the truth
is while studies performed on rats and
mice are undeniably useful their
applicability to humans can be limited
the overwhelming majority of treatments
that work on lab mice do not wind up
succeeding in humans which means two
things a we shouldn't rush out to report
rodent results and be during lab mouse
funerals when they say at least he
didn't die in vain most of the time they
are like oh I know it hurts to hear that
but them's the brakes Mouse now now to
be fair it's not always the news media
sometimes researchers themselves will
oversimplify the science even TED Talks
which have had some amazing speakers
have also featured some morning show
style science in the past like Paul
Zak's
2011 talk on a hormone produced in the
brain called oxytocin which he even gave
a catchy name to this little syringe
contains the moral molecule it's so easy
to cause people's brains to release
oxytocin I know how to do it and my
favorite way to do it is in fact the
easiest let me show it to you come here
give me hook
there you go here's your prescription
from dr. love eight hugs a day we have
found that people release more oxytocin
are happier and they're happier because
they have better relationships of all
types dr. love says eight hugs a day
first of all don't call yourself dr.
love
that's the nickname of tabloid gives a
dentist to ejaculate it on his sedated
patients and second second there is no
way that I would be happier giving eight
hugs a day I'm English that is four
lifetime's worth of hugs I look but now
you probably won't be surprised to learn
the real science on oxytocin is more
complicated than the term moral molecule
suggests because while it has been found
to enhance positive emotions like
bonding and Trust researchers have also
found that it can enhance negative
emotions like envy and bias so while
promising the science on this is still
very much in progress which probably
explains why a recent survey of oxytocin
research warned the reports about it
influencing a large number of social
behaviors should be viewed with healthy
skepticism which is really a long
technical way of saying what you
probably knew in the first place which
is when a strange man calling himself
dr. love offers to hug you eight times a
day say no and you can see you can see
just about all of the problems that I've
described plus one more in a study that
made the rounds last year the new study
claims that driving while dehydrated is
just as dangerous as driving drunk
researchers say drivers who drank just
one ounce of water per hour
made the same number of mistakes on the
road as those over the legal limit with
alcohol doctor when I heard this I
thought this cannot be true yeah
obviously it couldn't because it wasn't
true as Britain's National Health
Service had already pointed out that
study was riddled with red flags
including that it was based on just 12
men of whom data was only reported for
11 and it got funding from the European
hydration Institute
a foundation that's received over seven
million dollars from coca-cola a company
that just happens to sell rehydration in
the form of a fizzy brown sugar water
carbonated urine flat urine diet you're
in and grapefruit flavored embalming
fluid and look just because a study is
industry funded or its sample size was
small or it was done on mice doesn't
mean it's automatically flawed but it is
something the media reporting on it
should probably tell you about and you
may think well hold on where's the harm
here so long as I don't try to fart
cancer away or for later bear no one's
getting hurt but I'm not so sure about
that because think of it this way this
is a chart mapping the results of
studies of things like coffee eggs and
wine all of them have been linked to
raising or lowering your risk of cancer
depending on the study and everything
causes cancer is not the conclusion you
want to draw from science it's the
conclusion you should draw from logging
onto WebMD where that is their motto
because if I were to tell you about each
of those studies in isolation at some
point you might reasonably think well no
one knows anything about what causes
cancer and that is a problem because
that's the sort of thing that enable
tobacco companies for years to insist
the science isn't in yet and if you
think I'm exaggerating about the impact
that this misreporting can have on our
faith in science look at an example from
some of the people most guilty of it
because the Today Show which lives for
scientific studies recently concluded
one segment like this like a lot of
studies that we love around here they've
been a couple especially related to
women write about the benefits as I get
all serious on whole milk hey-ho milk
but it's true there's a lot of research
though that says actually having whole
milk more having whole fat yeah
dairy products actually can help you
lose weight I think the way to live your
life as you find the study that sounds
best to me and you don't wish yeah no no
in science in science you don't just get
to cherry-pick the parts that justify
what you are going to do anyway that's
religion you're thinking of religion
that is what you're thinking of there
this is dangerous this is really
dangerous if we start thinking that
science is a la carte and if you don't
like one study don't worry another will
be along soon that is what leads people
to think that manmade climate change
isn't real or that vaccines cause autism
both of which the scientific consensus
is pretty clear on science is by its
nature imperfect but it is hugely
important and it deserves better than to
be twisted out of proportion and turned
into morning show gossip so if they are
going to keep saying a study says they
should have to provide sourcing and
context or not mention it at all and I
know what you're thinking what hold on
if that happens where am I going to get
all my interesting from don't
worry we have you covered
do you love science in all its
complexity but wish it could be a little
less complex in a lot less scientific
introducing Todd talks with a format of
TED Talks meets the intellectual rigor
of morning news shows
chocolate mmm it will kill you what if I
were to tell you all that the cure to
racism is coffee and in my research I
found out red wine makes babies 20% more
sociable
that's a baby we can work with and Todd
talks we've raised the bar on
entertainment by lowering the bar on
what constitutes science our scientists
at the skittles foundation for rainbow
tasting have done some pioneering work
we placed 37 volunteers from Tulsa
Oklahoma on an all skittle diet for six
weeks and guess how many were killed by
baboons 134 people lived two were killed
in a non baboon related murder-suicide
why did we do this because you love
science but you don't want to hear it's
process act really depicted on a stage I
conducted a randomized double-blind
trial on the effects of coffee on cancer
of the esophagus and while there were
statistically significant decreases in
incidences of cancer in the mice that
were given the coffee compared to the
control group any definitive conclusions
will of course have to await human
trials peer review and replication now
of course this I think what he's trying
to say is coffee cures cancer yeah we
didn't we
you won't find our speakers at TED Talks
because they're not afraid to ask the
hard questions our eggs good for you
where are they bad for you what if I
were to tell you they were both what if
I were to tell you they were neither
what if I were to tell you they were
both and neither
well yeah Todd talks feature the kinds
of scientific insights that aren't just
uncredible they're incredible
stand but - but with me boom by standing
but - but we can actually increase our
serotonin levels how do you feel uh
weird weird
that's the serotonin working hey don't
move I'm gonna step out gonna come back
in and give you a boost
how's that feel ah she's speechless if
you like the idea of science you'll
absolutely love Todd talks people none
of what you're hearing here is science
science is a very slow and rigorous
process that does not lend itself easily
to sweeping come close Oh take it easy
pal sounds like somebody needs a
serotonin boos come on bring it in Todd
talks have been called insightful
inspiring and a clear trademark
infringement I guess what I'm not even a
scientist but my study shows that you
seem 70% more authoritative if you're
wearing a lab coat and I am thank you so
much
scientists there you go
another scientist
Todd talks because science doesn't have
to be an exact science
you